(indistinct chatter)
- [Narrator] ConGloms are an informal time
for the teacher and the
students to interact,
so it becomes a bonding time.
(students clap enthusiastically)
The ConGlom sets the tone for the day,
and throughout the course of the day
you see the team-building,
sharing ideas, opinions,
respecting each other.
- Both of us were having difficulty.
They did not just give up or blame us.
They helped us along.
- The mission of Riverside is
every child should graduate saying I can.
They should go out with
the confidence that yes,
I can deal with any
problem, any situation.
(students cheer happily)
- First thing in the
morning, what do we do?
- [Student] Conglom.
- Can we do a Conglom?
Yeah, you want a fun Conglom?
- [All Students] Yes!
- Conglom is a Riverside jargon.
It means coming together.
It actually comes from
the word conglomerate.
Conglom is like a morning meeting
where it is a pure
relationship building time.
They like the fact that this is
an unstructured time for them.
It's just talking time, maybe
playing a game together,
always trying to know each other.
- It helps me wake up from home.
And it helps me start my brain.
- One team over here.
We have different types of Congloms,
we have physical Congloms,
we have social intuition Congloms,
we have spiritual
Congloms where we look at
how am I growing my heart bigger.
- It's just like a good start to the day
because you don't want
to start the day with
studying or seeing books.
We either do an activity or we have some
specific topic to talk about.
- The need of the
Conglom comes mainly from
what is the need of the class.
- Maybe that class has a lot of tension
between the boys and girls.
Maybe they're getting totally
wrapped up in exam stress.
You kind of tailor those
Congloms with that.
- The Conglom that grade six had,
the topic was body awareness.
- We had a girl and boy Conglom separate.
When it's like completely girls,
then it's very comfortable
to say anything we want.
- So is it fair that someone teases you
because you are starting to grow breasts?
What else do you get teased for?
- Tuli was telling me that I
have a mustache and everything.
- He was calling her a hairy potato.
- So we also talk about
people calling us names
and saying that you're fat, you're thin.
So then we would also
shouted these to them.
- The first thing I would do is,
whatever is happening at that moment,
I would firmly say stop it
and second, I would approach a teacher.
- Questions about the
body or about behavior,
we would never approach our teachers,
maybe not even our parents,
but Congloms are a moment
when you don't get judged.
- Okay guys, we're gonna play a game.
Each team, three people will be mute,
two people will be blind,
and one person physically disabled.
Today's Conglom was an active game
to understand how my peers work,
to understand how I react
to certain situations
which are difficult and stressful for me.
Your challenge is to use
these cardboard pieces
to get your whole team
to reach the other side
of the lava pit.
- It was a team building activity.
It was about involving everyone
no matter how different or alike we are.
- Three, two, one, go!
- How our team goes, we were taking care
of the people blindfolded
because the mute people
could see and hear us, so we guided them,
and we took support of
them in terms of helping.
- Keep going, keep going!
(students cheer happily)
- We're in the journey together,
so Congloms help us grow an individual
who's going to go out into society
and be able to solve problems
and be able to understand
themselves and connect with
other people emotionally.
- We all have different
strengths and weaknesses.
Working as a class, we can cross the hole.
(students clap enthusiastically)
- Every morning, the students
look forward to the Conglom.
Even I look forward, as an educator.
It is absolute outstanding,
and we would not want
to miss it for anything.
(students cheer joyfully)